[Musica]
buongiorno
buongiorno a tutti grazie grazie per
l'invito per noi è veramente un piacere
e un onore essere qui su questo palco
dopo dopo due anni è anche il titolo
scelto quest'anno per il ted
sembra fatta apposta per noi forse è
stata fatta apposta per noi incontri con
andrea nonostante madre siamo entrambi
adesivi lavoriamo con base ad arezzo non
stanziamento di anni fa non ci
conoscevamo facevamo cose a volte come
dire parallele ma roma non aveva mai
avuto modo di incontrarci e vuoi anche
l'occasione del ted l'atmosfera
particolarmente entusiasmante diciamo
fertile di produzione di idee
abbiamo iniziato un percorso un progetto
che si chiama materia e che qualche modo
ha messo insieme le esperienze e le
particolarità di ciascuno di noi
così per ricordare a chi c'era appunto
due anni fa e mi occupo di architettura
di progettazione architettonica con
store studio architecture è voluto a
parlare di architettura contemporaneità
e invenzione della memoria
sostanzialmente nel mio lavoro cerca
appunto di mettere insieme lucio diciamo
della memoria inteso come elemento
creativo legato appunto anche a una
dimensione paesaggistica in un progetto
di contemporaneità e quindi quando ho
sentito andrea era venuto a illustrare
un utopia concreta che appunto all of
breed box una scatola magica mi ha
subito dato il via per appunto pensare a
un qualcosa a un nuovo progetto che
unisce gli elementi di natura di energia
e di paesaggio e anche e anche di design
sì grazie stefano
intanto io voglio ecco partire da
raccontare questo percorso che abbiamo
fatto insieme e proprio dal concetto da
cui ero partito anche due anni fa quando
sono salito su questo palco per la prima
volta è il concetto di sostenibilità è
un concetto che sentiamo di cui sentiamo
parlare spesso è anche in modo vago
invece noi intendiamo dargli un
perimetro un perimetro molto chiaro e
molto definito che chiedendosi un po e
che cosa è realmente sostenibile beh
sicuramente sostenibile un sistema
chiuso che prende le risorse di cui ha
bisogno è solo e soltanto dal territorio
nel quale insiste e che rimette gli
scarti e i rifiuti appunto che genera
solo e soltanto nel territorio nel quale
insiste così si eliminano un po quelle
esternalità negative che si creano
nel soddisfare i nostri bisogni e che
invece si allontanano sia nello spazio
pensiamo alle guerre insomma per
l'approvvigionamento energetico sia nel
tempo magari pensiamo ai cambiamenti
climatici
invece se tutto questo ricade nel
territorio dove il territorio ha un
perimetro molto precisa non può essere
un concetto vago può essere il ter il
territorio il perimetro della città o
può essere anche il perimetro del mio
giardino
ad esempio se invece non allontano
queste esternalità questo mi costringe
ad essere virtuoso perché ovviamente
qualunque cosa di negativo
creo alla natura all'ambiente me lo
ritrovo me lo ritrovo nel mio giardino
appunto e qui appunto eravamo partiti la
volta scorsa per questo è il concetto di
off grid non off grid vuol dire staccate
staccati da quelle reti che allontanano
appunto queste esternalità negative
quindi mi costringono a far forza
soltanto sulle forze della natura pre
pre presenti sul mio territorio e
parlavamo appunto di of duty box che
questo concetto che è diventato pro
prodotto per noi della fabbrica del sole
appunto un locale tecnico che
permettesse in modo semplice di
staccarsi completamente da dalle reti e
quindi
con pannelli fotovoltaici appunto è una
serie di impianti raccolte all'interno
di questo container facilmente
trasportabile si vedeva prima che era
anche trasportabile attraverso una
piccola zattera insomma è anche perché i
primi le prime applicazioni appunto si
sono si sono avute su quei luoghi dove i
bisogni ad esempio l'elettricità o
l'acqua non erano non erano presenti
vuoi perché abbandonati o poi perché non
c'erano mai stati quindi nel corso di
questi due anni abbiamo fatto molte
installazioni un po un po in tutto il
mondo dalle filippine al sud africa al
[Musica]
madagascar la colombia e ovviamente
anche in italia e qui da questo con te
né da dall'italia e dando a questo
container che alle volte bianco le volte
blu
siamo partiti a in un progetto parallelo
diciamo fuso parallelo con con stefano a
ragionare su altro sì diciamo il punto
di partenza quindi era già da una
tecnologia diciamo esistente efficiente
di grandi potenzialità per l'abitare
abbiamo cercato di fare un salto di
qualità cioè quindi quella di rendere
questo nuovo oggetto nuovo sistema che
non avesse più il gap del farsi vedere
cioè quindi di renderlo come dire alla
pari di altri elementi ma dire antropici
presente sul territorio avendo in
prospettiva l'abitare in contesti di
questo tipo cioè o in nuovi territori ma
anche il re appropriarsi di territori
come dire che con il tempo sono stati
lasciati per motivi si sarebbe detto una
volta legati alla modernità appunto
senza luce e senza acqua moglie si
preferiva
recarsi in città e lasciare come abbiamo
anche noi come di rendere le nostre zone
tante case abitazioni non più abitate
perché appunto non avevano questo tipo
di comodità il concetto il percorso che
ci siamo voluti da te era appunto di
restituire questa possibilità e di
riappropriarsi di un ambiente tramite
non vivibile avendo appunto come
riferimenti o anche perché viviamo in un
ambiente nel territorio un paesaggio di
grande qualità di grande pregio questi
riferimenti ci siamo detti se funziona
da noi può funzionare in qualsiasi in
qualsiasi luogo e sostanzialmente
provando ma dirà a innescare un'azione
centripeta appunto dalla città vuoi dire
che possa ridistribuirsi verso verso il
esterno verso il territorio avendo
presente nel diciamo in questo percorso
progettuale anche tanti elementi che
fanno parte un po della nostra storia
quindi tutta la nostra tradizione della
sistemazione del paesaggio dei territori
agricoli dei giardini ma anche elementi
che ci vengono dalla natura e che spesso
sono come dire sovrapponibili quasi ai
sistemi energetici di produzione di
energia
tutto questo per in estrema sintesi ha
portato a questo sistema
questo strano oggetto che forse lo
vedremo eccolo qui che si chiama materia
e che cos'è materia è un sistema dove
partendo dalla punto dall asp grip box
sia la possibilità di articolare una
serie di necessità ma anche di nuove
funzioni quindi diventa un
un oggetto nuovo non ne abbiamo trovati
di simili diciamo attualmente vedere
sulla faccia della terra
non sappiamo se sia utile o meno però è
un elemento diciamo che non esiste come
dire tipologicamente cioè diventa
appunto produzione di energia raccolta
contiene appunto il sistema fotovoltaico
ma anche come dire una zona di ricarica
per i veicoli elettrici per le bici
elettriche
quindi un qualcosa che diciamo
funzionalmente abbastanza articolato e
che appunto anche formalmente però è
individuabile una forma quasi appunto
che richiama in maniera quasi archetipa
invaso quindi la raccolta che però si
può porre in qualsiasi tipo di contesto
senza come dire avere un problema come
dire di tipo estetico a monte ecco
l'ambiente o medi estremamente delicato
come possono essere le nostre nostre
campagne insomma forse uno dei territori
più belli al mondo appunto diciamo regge
il confronto senza nome dire rinnegare
la propria contemporaneità
oggi e confronto con qualsiasi altro
elemento di natura antropica e quindi
può essere applicabile in qualsiasi
contesto a seconda naturalmente delle
caratteristiche delle delle tipologie
tecnologiche sì in questo io sono
convinto che sia un oggetto molto utile
perché perché poi di fatto il materia
conserva il cuore tecnologico della fit
boxe quindi a pannelli fotovoltaici per
la raccolta dell'energia solare per
l'appunto è un sistema di raccolta
dell'acqua piovana e rende disponibili
acqua e corrente per appunto l'edificio
al per il quale è a servizio chiaramente
può essere diciamo anche un po quello
che diceva stefano con questi moduli può
essere anche un po adattato alle
esigenze sia del territorio nel quale
nel quale insiste quindi con le fonti
che abbiamo a disposizione come ad
esempio può essere il vento o altre
fonti d'acqua o così anche adattato
anche alle esigenze diverse per il per
l'edificio per il gruppo di edifici per
il quale al servizio componendo appunto
delle varie composizioni trasformandolo
sempre in un oggetto diverso però
diciamo con con la sua funzione ta
quindi questo ci consente anche un
dimensione in un dimensionamento di tipo
ingegneristico che abbastanza flessibile
e chiaramente le caratteristiche sono
sono quelle che ci dicevamo viene
recuperata l'energia la raccoglie
raccolta propria energia dal vento e dal
sole messa a disposizione quindi poi per
l'edificio anche per altri servizi come
può essere il riscaldamento viene
raccolta l'acqua piovana
così come viene utilizzata anche altra
acqua che è disponibile sul posto e
messa a disposizione dell'edificio
un aspetto importantissimo è questo
anche della ricarica dei veicoli
elettrici perché non pensiamo soltanto
alle esigenze dell'edificio ma anche
alle esigenze di chi lo abita quindi la
sostenibilità non soltanto dell'edificio
stesso ma proprio degli usi
delle persone quindi la sostenibilità
nei trasporti non soltanto pensiamo a
veicoli elettrici insomma ormai la
strada è abbastanza tracciata questa nel
trasporto vediamo un po un po tutti i
giorni nell'esigenza di veicoli
elettrici ma anche pensiamo ad esempio
al cicloturismo in zone remote nelle
quali appunto vogliamo andare ad
applicarci cicloturismo elettrico per
dire che consente anche a magari persone
meno allenati come i miei magari di
andare a scoprire dei territori che
appunto per adesso sono ammalati
diciamo a conclusione quindi un percorso
diciamo di concepimento di maturazione
del progetto che ha visto coinvolti
tanti amici e colleghi siamo passati
alla realizzazione di un primo prototipo
di un numero zero grazie alla
fondamentale collaborazione di fabio
sbraci nell'ingegnerizzazione un
elemento diciamo che abbiamo cercato di
mantenere costante nella filosofia anche
dell'oro blu box è quella di un oggetto
un sistema che sia facilmente
realizzabile facilmente trasportabile di
è anche semplice assemblamento pensando
che potrebbe andare in qualsiasi parte
del mondo è questo diciamo alla fase di
realizzazione
paolo nicchi che ci ha dato il suo
fondamentale contributo per diciamo la
parte di attacco a terra perché è un
elemento importante anche questo dove
sarà piantato vuoi dire sarà
completamente reversibili quindi non
fratelli cemento cose varie
vuol dire elementi puntiformi che poi
vengono vengono portati via
durante la fase di montaggio
la scelta del sito che come dire va a
chiudere un po anche qui in maniera
coerente secondo il nostro il nostro
percorso
siamo sul mondo infinito sopra cortona
in un posto meraviglioso tra la val di
chiana la valtiberina con questa
terrazza sul lago trasimeno un luogo era
stato abbandonato quindi di abitazioni
lasciate quindi non più non più abitate
e che sarà la sede della fit academy
esatto il luogo scelto non è a caso è
già sede appunto della nostra guida
accademiche abbiamo avuto appunto questi
edifici in concessione che stiamo
recuperando rendendo scriverlo l'abito
accademy vuole essere anche un po te
dove applichiamo le tecnologie ocr it
dove vengono fatti dei corsi per appunto
illustrativo confluite in questo caso il
materia sarà che quindi strumento
didattico per questo e anche tornando al
tema o poi della giornata anche un punto
di incontro dove si incontrano appunto
professionalità idee anche per vacanza
ho capito cosa del genere dove appunto
si vede applicata tutto quello che è il
concetto di rock script prevede quindi
non soltanto
vediamo anche magari agricoltura e
all'altra insomma proprio vedere
immagini dei tanti pochi giorni fa cioè
l'installazione appunto del dei primi
moduli quindi semplicità di montaggio
vede trasportabilità con mezzi molto
semplice il buon paolo ricchi che si
installano materialmente le viti
ecco il montaggio di una prima parte
questo è un diciamo foto inserimento di
cosa andremo a completare da qui a poco
tempo e questo diciamo che sarà il
risultato finale di questo di questo
numero zero che appunto potrà essere
visionata che farà un po da apripista
speriamo ha un futuro
diciamo spero come dire interessante per
molti
vorrei ringraziare
naturalmente questo un lavoro che vede
partecipi molte persone naturalmente gli
amici della fabbrica del sole emiliano
cecchini e da vedevo un signore store
studio e in particolare l'architetto
francesco coleschi che oltre a seguire
la parte progettuale si è occupato anche
dell'immagine è estremamente importante
e vi vogliamo salutare con una frase che
secondo noi raccoglie un po tutto quello
che vi abbiamo detto quindi bellezza
natura energia quindi accumulo che rete
che speriamo sia sempre più green
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]